what's going on reject nation we are
here to watch the season finale of
pacemaker this has been an amazing
journey i want to thank everyone who's
been with us since the first episode
even in spite of all the copyright
claims and limited ads this has been an
amazing journey speaking of claims we
got a sponsor for today's video and this
is a sponsor that i've been trying to
work with for quite a while because
every time i see them shattered out on a
youtube video i go why haven't they
contacted us yet the second they did i
went yes thank you and that is displate
display offers more than a million
designs from over 40 000 artists from
beautiful original art to some of our
favorite ips like marvel star wars and
dc and each one is individually printed
on super durable metal by disc plates
master of production and the best part
is they're super easy to install and
switch out we just hung two minutes
before shooting you don't need any power
tools which is great for a guy like me
thanks to their magnet based mounting
system which takes all of about 20
seconds to install display and start
swapping out your disc plates since
we're here in greg's home he got this
awesome batman disc plate which is now
being displayed proudly right behind his
head along with a few other pretty
awesome ones that you'll see probably in
the coming week display ships to over 56
countries in about four to five business
days so now's the perfect time to start
growing and showing your collection my
collection is a grower this plates are
great alternatives to paper and canvas
printing and when you hit our special
link down in the description box you'll
get an extra little discount on your
order which is about the most patriotic
thing i can think of like peacemaker so
support the channel by checking out some
awesome disc plates yes they sent us
over a couple for free because we're
doing a sponsorship but i already have
some queued up that i'm going to buy
already myself
let's make some peace by checking out
some face makeup
mom there are way more butterflies than
we thought and the whole team is injured
so i was thinking like maybe you could
call in the justice league which version
of the justice league human torpedo to
aim your head at whatever you want to
destroy and you become a human torpedo
sweet yeah
put it on adrian i'm gonna put a walkie
in it and activate it from here and then
maybe you can put on activate
anti-gravity and just float it over
there uh guys oh
[ __ ] deactivate any gravity deactivate
anti-gravity
ugh
dude fishing line over the barn for one
of these trees here and just let the
helmets slide down like green arrow no
not like green
we're only conventions dressed in the
back half of twilight sparkle with a
four-inch wide butthole drilled in the
costume maybe so we can breathe properly
actually mention queen hero no i
actually heard that's true about green
arrow but that's the first thing he said
that's real an aquaman [ __ ] fish well
yeah obviously
but we do have a team member capable of
flight
legally
i need you
to take that helmet
and drop it on top of that barn
no way can an eagle understand what
you're saying you don't know this eagle
prove her wrong eagly
take it
no eagle you just take it take the
helmet take it eagley take the helmet
evie take the helmet
[Laughter]
good english good good
ziggly doing it
be safe eagley
for the love of god
oh no [ __ ] are you doing get my poison
blue gun [ __ ] why don't you just go for
your peace cubs dane you're metaphorical
douche wad my gun's real i don't want
the butterflies to hear ha i almost
tricked you
oh
so i can kill you all over again
what are you doing
nothing
holy [ __ ]
huh
ghost dead
oh
ouch
that was brutal
the only way for us to get the helmet
inside of the barn is by one of us going
in under cover john you're the only one
and why are these wet wash them in the
creek why one of the things those
warriors seldom talk about is how often
people [ __ ] themselves when they die
they're aliens do they even speak
english they retain the memories of the
bodies they've taken over so they seem
to primarily use english when
communicating
head towards the bar and let you know
what you're doing
relax your face shut up
you relax your face
hey
i'm going inside
why
tell them what to say because of this
bag okay
just wanted to make sure
oh
no
whoa
no
[ __ ] it
no more kind juicy
no more kaijus
it's a nice call back to the suicide
squad yeah i tell my ass it's a
[ __ ]
stop talking
the man you've taken over
why did he do that to his beard
why did he color his beard all strange
like that he thought it made him look
younger and
more handsome
had a girlfriend so he thought dying his
beard might help
but he was also lazy
and busy with his
job and when he did use the cheapest
brand because he was
incredibly underpaid
he never thought anybody noticed until
recently when one guy said it to him all
the time
that's awful oh dude
don't make me cry right now die beard
tie beard
l'oreal probably is worth the extra few
bucks hey
that guy just put this down here oh no
save him [ __ ] do it now
what the [ __ ]
oh
no
hands
save him
oh
no
activate sonic oh
[Applause]
yeah like three to four charges right
yeah
nice nice
[Music]
oh i feel bad for this cow
i know it's got one tooth it must be a
baby
[Music]
that's it for the charges
full on shield
i can help we need you to stay here ads
if something happens to us you're the
only hope what's the plan man
let's go kill a cow
[Applause]
cause i'm waiting for this on to come
into the blood
because of copyright you won't hear much
of it
blood bath
[Laughter]
cool
[Music]
oh
wow
awesome
that's so cool
chris go kill the cow we'll hold here
no
oh
man that was a brutal fall get up
peacemaker
oh
[ __ ] oh no no
oh you got to be kidding me no
oh no come on no
no no
she's your girlfriend james good
you can't do it
gotta be in season two
the [ __ ] do we do
what are you doing we get out there
little attibuy you can't you'll get hurt
do a wheel hey what makes you think you
can do this because i'm made for this
[ __ ] she's the daughter of waller that's
right
[Music]
oh what the [ __ ] oh my god
no
no no no keep your mouth closed
[Music]
oh oh no
[Music]
damn you got there fast man yeah a good
crawler
my god she has become peacemaker
the ark
get mislead
wow
what a shot
activate
[Music]
stop fighting follow me
was this just a big misunderstanding our
kind traveled here from a planet that
had become unlivable
the cow would help the last of our
people survive for another hundred years
not long after we arrived we realized
the people of earth were on the exact
same trajectory as our people had been
ignoring science in favor of populist
leaders who tell you that the floods and
the fires and the disease are unrelated
to your own actions treating minor
inconveniences as assaults on your
freedom
damn
heavy [ __ ]
we made a vow to make the choices for
you that you were incapable of making on
your own to save your people and your
world no matter how many lives it cost
us peace
no matter how many
men women and children we gotta kill to
get it thank you for feeding me and
talking to me and showing me kindness
join us in saving your planet
activate human torpedo
oh
let him live
no
no
[Music]
oh
what what
[Music]
sick of that it's really him
it's
not a rumor
holy balls
i can't believe my god this guy's
[ __ ] buried
oh man dang is that henry cavill i
didn't know henry cavill no girl oh
[Music]
yeah dude you're shot
you got to be admitted
i'm fine seriously
all i need is a good nap
[Laughter]
why did you choose not to help them
because of your proto-fascist
libertarian idea of freedom
because i knew they'd hurt you and the
others if i did i'm sorry i betrayed you
amanda large blows it off
don't tell v but
after eagley you're my bff
[Music]
[Music]
both the peacemaker
and the costumed crime fighter vigilante
were working in a deep cover operation
oh god this is all part of a black ops
program known as task force x whoa dang
it's been running for years out of belle
reef prison oh dang command of
of a woman named amanda waller
what the [ __ ]
you've been out there for days
oh hold his head
the costumes
[Music]
the real peace is the friends we made
along the way
no way
have they removed the body
i would hope by now
oh
eagley
it's like a perfect season yeah
no near perfect season it was really
peacefully done yeah
wow
golly
that's crazy
justin to show up like that
yeah i would i did not see that coming
one of the shots was like what i look
like that's a really good uh looking uh
double for uh jason that's jason
still has to live with that
that haunting shadow of his father and
his life
you can't just get over something like
that that's a good way to keep robert
patrick around for season two yeah
can't get off that easy
sarcasm i haven't noticed you eating way
more corn chips than anyone human being
should eat and i'm not
worried that you're gonna die oh but i
am worried you're gonna die thanks
thanks
[Laughter]
beautiful
crazy beautiful
beautiful
oh yes good stuff well that was one hell
of a finale i think i think what's
interesting though is because you have
this justice league cameo that's
probably gonna be the first thing that
everyone's
mainly talking about in terms of
what this episode did
and here we are talking the first thing
we're talking about
yeah it's going to be the
room
because i overshadow everything
available we'll get it out of the way
then really quick because um yeah like
you know when you have the four p
there's no cyborg there's no batman
interesting choice
i do wonder i i bet he had to like james
gunn had to probably consult a little
bit i wonder i wonder i imagine he would
have to have had some type of discussion
of like who he could use and who he
couldn't use yeah
and it's like you know getting out of
those kind of a hard prospect but you
know getting uh it's like they kept
superman vague yeah as to who he is
some shots i'm like could be a supergirl
even
no cyborg definitely stands out cyborg
definitely could have been there the
blue lighting
is
snyder
whereas we've been saying with the flash
it's more yellow as of late
um
but
yeah this is james gunn saying restore
the snyder merch
i could see some people being upset that
we didn't get like a clear-cut henry
cavill that it's like just pure shazam
type of cameo in a way
um but
i liked it i was i was so in awe that i
wasn't even really processing the
dialogue there at the time yeah yeah
yeah i might start going like hey you
got them it's going to become this this
would be something more significant for
the future of the dceu
this is implying a whole bunch of new
spin-offs involving the same squad and
the justice league yeah that old joking
banter about you know [ __ ] another
fish i was like hope that didn't even
really process it humorous sometimes i
was like really
really late to it
but uh yeah that was surprising and but
in terms of like a season overall it
it's interesting i like the ambiguity of
how they ended it with chris at the end
you know with seeing his dad there on
the porch beside him like he's it seems
like he's gained some freedom now that
he's not no he's no longer part task
force x he gets to live there as just
himself to let him go free i imagine
there's no bomb in his head anymore um
and as much as he's coming to his own
and has made friends and such and can
live his own life form his own identity
you know it's he did kill his father and
his father's a big part of what shaped
him into the person he was throughout
this whole journey
so i like that kind of like he'll be
okay but there's still more work that
has to do that he will still be
haunted by this thing and it's like can
chris still go on can chris still
function you know and i think it's like
a neat more realistic
uh nuanced way to end
his journey that he's been on so far
where he's still like
he still has disturbing traumatic things
he has to work through
in spite of the fact of how much better
of a human being he has evolved uh
throughout the course of this journey so
i think that's a it's a powerful poetic
way to end all this
you know like it seemed like okay the
big part of what would allow chris to be
free is to free himself of his father
and now in death
he's still haunted by him this is very
fascinating stuff and i like the
the
sometimes i'm not a big fan of like
ghost dad or first especially to happen
so soon you know because like last
episode he died in the very next episode
so he's already experiencing ghost dad
but
it works here for me
well i think it's the simple twist that
it's an antagonistic presence and it's a
struggle it's not like some ambiguous
thing that is you know encouraging him
or motivating him to act and it's not
something that's coming out of comfort
it's it's a you know it's
it's the lack of freedom you know uh
that was achieved in that action it's
like yeah even though he wiped his dad
out the guilt and all the things that
would be you know just sort of warmed
into your psyche from so many years of
this person are still there and so yeah
it feels like an authentic device
because it spells
trouble for chris moving ahead and
torment of some variety for him moving
ahead and of all the things like that
they did a really nice job of yeah
bringing all these character arcs
especially for chris to a very graceful
close by the end of the season and
having ghost dad around is about the one
thing at this juncture i i like when a
show can end in a way where i'm like
damn what what are you gonna do for
season two like where are we gonna go
with this character but that's one
nugget where i'm like well he's
definitely gonna have to keep on dealing
with
the fallout from that and it's nice
because you know i mean
as much as uh auggie smith is a terrible
terrible terrible human being of a
character it also makes it feel like you
know the presence not that i guess there
are a lot of white dragon fans out there
who are like ah gone too soon but you
know it allows you to maintain that
character well beyond too and keep a
terrific actor in robert patrick so very
true yeah
it's they let every character arc here
at a bio i mean just with her journey of
being able to just live in truth for the
first time
not feel like she has to hide anymore
like accept who she's the daughter of
unveil the truth of what's been going on
like not continue on
the
evil deeds of what her mother does
because that she seemed like she was go
that was the path she was headed down
was just following in the footsteps of
the messed up twisted ways amanda waller
is
and instead exposes it all
which i gotta imagine creates some type
of trajectory for the dceu moving
forward at least in terms of how you
handle task force x which has always
been a very secretive program
and now to make it public that does
shift
how things can move forward like i i
wonder what ramifications this series
will
lead with with the movies i know we got
flashpoint coming up which is gonna mess
with time the way the timeline is here
uh however i'm like okay i mean we're
just gonna like stick with a specific
timeline for peacemaker and watch how
the ramifications of that unfold will
there be another suicide squad movie
you know it's supposed to be another
spin-off in the works if there were
anything oh yeah but we don't know what
it is no yeah um so yeah and then even
with uh dye beard
which is so touching you know i thought
it was cool to like finally acknowledge
that bring it back around
and you see there when he rx as well
like he's
essentially the short version as he felt
like a loser that his entire life
and you know like he was never accepted
into something and then he goes back to
his shitty desk job
but
he has he's generated a memory
he's generating an experience where he
felt worthy and connected
you know everybody really had to rise to
occasions yeah
yeah i think that's cool and then
harcourt obviously you know morphing
into a leader and learning to trust
connect
or she always shut people off
so they had really great
character journeys like throughout it it
was awesome it was really cool like i
thought everyone parked really well and
of course with the butterflies
you know it's like the most overtly
political it seems this show has gotten
yeah
for peacemaker especially who was
pitched to us initially
um with the lead up to the suicide squad
is like messed up version of captain
america at least that's kind of the way
john cena put it
and obviously just with you know what
who the character is
there's naturally a political
inheritance that comes with the
exploration of his dad and what he
stands for yeah yeah
uh but to find out the motivations is
probably the most
you know political commentating of the
current way the state of the world is
in a way that's most likely to trigger
people like oh you're getting a
political night show but i don't know i
thought it was a fresh spin on
on aliens you know like we've because
when our first
when she was for uh goth was first
unveiling
what their motive was i'm like okay i've
heard this like a billion times of like
oh our planet sucked and we were we
needed sources so we came here
you know
and then to put an extra spin on it of
we saw you guys were actually headed on
the same path path our planet was on and
a lot of it has to do with the way your
leadership decides to avoid things and
and chalk it up to being something else
just completely be dismissive of the
fact that your race is responsible for
why this earth is deteriorating and
that's going to lead to your extinction
so we're going to try to change it you
know
i thought that like made a very
like that
that's refreshing to me in a way that it
feels apt to the way the world is today
yeah i thought they articulated that
really really well and i think that
helps to sell it because yeah it keeps
it from being the flimsy old oh you
you're not capable of steering your own
ship let us do it for you haha like yeah
i i loved that they were able to bring
you to a point where when adebayo asks
him why didn't you help them
there's a decent conversation to be had
surrounding that and ultimately yeah it
does come down to we need to be able to
make our own choices whether or not
those are the right choices we
need to maintain that autonomy but you
know by that point where uh yeah goff is
laying it out i was like oh
in this moment even though i don't i
ultimately don't imagine he will help
them i'm still kind of conflicted and i
can see this as being a difficult you
know sort of moment of truth right here
and i think it's exemplary throughout
the whole show that yeah you have so
many rich character beats rich sub
textual beats like that alongside
it never there's something magic about
the way james gunn writes these things
where it feels like it has it all in the
sense that you know you've got a really
rollicking well-paced fun sci-fi
adventure with crazy bone-crunching
action and yet it's never at the expense
of
you know real resonant character like
this made me like cry a couple times
just for the personal relationships as
well as like the sort of desperate like
for as much as there have been scenes
where the butterflies are very sinister
like i did start to feel for them and
even for the cow by the end of wow this
is just sort of a really messed up
circumstance they're doing the best that
they can it doesn't really click exactly
with what we are and how we exist here
and that's a muddy situation and it
feels appropriate for you know
a task force x type of operation to deal
with this and then to ultimately have
that debate
and uh yeah it was i was
it was any and even you know further on
when she's asking him like what are you
gonna do with your like proto-fascist
libertarian however she she sizes him up
like there's so much wonderful
understanding
of the sort of image of the character
and then what informs that at the core
and uh yeah it's it's like a really
wonderful deconstruction without having
that be like the main thing about it you
know
yeah
i think it's interesting what they did
with the cow is is kind of similar to
starro in a lot of ways
of um you know like this creature really
doesn't have malicious evil intent no
and i feel bad for it in the end when
it's dying
it's almost yeah it's it's sadder
because in this sense this one's way
sadder than the star yeah it's just
chilling and it's just doing its thing
you know for its species or for you know
it's adjacent and it had a chance to
live just teleported out
yeah
yeah no they did a really great job at
layering it that was a unexpected thing
but
uh the action was good too some of the
best action of the whole series i would
say uh for the whole fight at the end it
was really rewarding cathartic and i
even liked that a bio got to come in
there and whoop some ass too
but a lot of the way the gun play was
done was really really cool don't play
the stunts the camera choreography
combined with the fight choreography
especially in that long take where
they're fighting all the butterflies
like that was mightily impressive i'd be
very
curious to hear james gunn's breakdown
of the use of the theme song because it
always felt like it
had a different
mood or tone per opening scene yeah
right like it was the same song and we
heard someone telling us that james got
talked about this recently aaron
alexander our friend was talking to us
about this that he said james scott was
talking about it and i always felt that
that in some ways that always
re-contextualized a little bit
but then to use it at that specific
scene too i'm like i really
wonder what the purpose is of
like what's his vision of
you know of using it and and what it
really meant to him yeah because it's a
unique experience because yeah it's like
when you upon repeat
hearing the song over each episode yeah
there's something uncanny that i haven't
been able to identify but yeah it does
feel different every time but i don't
think i've ever experienced that
because you know so many things don't
have a reason to report a song over and
over but yeah like that that is a nuance
i i find very sort of elusive but
impressive
oh here we are guys peacemaker overall
the pretty amazing season i do like a
solid minimum like 9.8
at a time
i try to think back and like
who were some things i complained about
it was never much they made vigilante a
bit more dumb
you know in the previous two episodes
but that's about the only thing i could
think of a bit more dumb than he needed
to be maybe but
i can't really think of her to gripe
about no i've been i've been so
enthralled on every like it's fun it's
got the cool action [ __ ] it's got some
touching qualities it's got sometimes
the banter moments don't really work for
me
99 of the time they do but like every
once in a while there's a scene where
i'm like
yeah it's like the whole ant scene i
didn't really find that funny
yeah and i guess the saving grace to me
is that even in the banter bits that i
wouldn't necessarily be laughing at they
still felt in character so i was fine
with them just being scenes sure
that's what i mean yeah there's always a
way to like kind of explain it it
equally gets to live
i'm so happy guys what did you think
about peacemaker finale overall and what
do you think about the season overall
leave your thoughts down below
thank you for being here and thank you
again to display for sponsoring this
video hit up the links in the
description box to get yourself
displayed order as well and last but not
least let's do a paper
scuba steve scuba i think you would be a
wonderful addition to the peacemaker
cast when season two rolls around think
about it they talked about it here in
this episode too going underwater with
that peacemaker helmet that might not
come in handy but clearly they can't
rely on aquaman so they need some kind
of obscure
weird eccentric superhero that
borderline criminal that they would need
to join with them on their mission to go
in underwater who better than scuba
steve looks incapable looks goofy at
first but then bam you put him under
water
gets killed off in the first 30 seconds
of his screen time drowns apparently
scuba steve wasn't reliable and you're
used for a throwaway bit just when we
think you might be able to help us out
you die first 30 seconds why'd you let
us down but for you
moment of fame
what more could you ask for
see i did that i subverted expectations
yeah there you go then scuba steve shows
up in the post credit scene and you
think he's going to be alive
but he's just still dead he's just dead
he's just dead we subvert expectations
by not being creative enough to come up
with what the scenario would be for
scuba tv to get involved or what the
power set would be don't want to do all
that thank you
this is better
[Music]